winter is coming and if you're gonna go
out you better make it memorable
this will be the last of my game of
thrones list that i get out before the
new season begins and it's the one i had
the most fun with i'm going to count
down the top 10
deaths this is a show that has given us
a heck of a body count a lot of
characters gone out in a lot of
different ways some better than others i
want to pick my favorites ultimately
this is a subjective list this is these
are just the deaths that made me go oh
the most for whatever reason so with
that in mind here we go with number 10
rob stark you know the red wedding was
going to be on here somewhere but
because that event encompassed so many
individual deaths and i'm only doing
them one at a time we're gonna start
with rob and a lot of ways this was just
sort of the impact of the loss of that
character but in addition to that just
kind of how drawn out it was i mean you
kind of realized he was screwed for me
was when they killed the direwolf as
soon as that happened like there's no
way he's getting out of that room but it
then it just kind of draws it out as he
gets hit with the arrows but he's still
standing and his mother's screaming at
him to run and there's just no hope left
it's kind of painful in a way but it
makes it all the more impactful number
nine lysa aaron i actually kind of
wanted to put this one higher because
this was a character i was very happy to
see die and just sort of the suddenness
of it and just the impact it had on her
of her suddenly realizing how she had
completely put her stock in the wrong
person seeing that hit her just before
she got pushed off with all that into
account i wanted to put her higher on
the list but the actual look of it her
falling through it it looks kind of
cheesy unfortunately i do have to knock
this death for that number eight ned
stark ned topped my list of favorite
dead characters and boy his death
definitely left an impact and it really
just sunk in at that moment like
characters do not get that miraculous
save you see it in almost every other
sort of story where someone a character
who's so vital is about to die but then
some miraculous thing happens and some
character swoops in at the last minute
you're you're looking around you're
waiting for that that save to happen and
come and it doesn't and the sword just
swings down and that's it i don't think
there were many deaths that are quite as
impactful on the overall sort of
assessment you have of the show as the
death of ned number seven shea a bit
like lysa she's on here because i wanted
her to die so
bad and to not only have her die but
have tyrion the one who she took in and
then betrayed so fundamentally and she
just even before the betrayal she was
dragging him down so much for him to be
the one to just choke her out
oh that was cathartic and the only
reason this death isn't higher is kind
of how damaging you saw it was for
tyrion to have to do that i felt bad for
tyrion at the same time that i felt
really good that she was getting killed
so that sort of internal conflict makes
it a very strong moment but makes the
actual death slightly less enjoyable so
that's why i didn't go higher as happy
as i was to see shae
get just
oh it was nice number six egret now when
i did my list of dead characters she did
actually make the list and in a lot of
ways her death was handled incredibly
well it was handled exactly how it
needed to be to continue to elevate that
character because when she first showed
up in season three honestly i kind of
hated her i hated the pairing of her and
jon snow i felt to devalue both
characters to have them sort of fall for
each other the way they did but then
when he switches sides that immediately
brought her back up because she was not
going to take that lying down and she
held on to that right up to the end and
she's got him in her sights and she does
pause for just a moment but they had her
die at the exact right moment because if
they'd waited any longer or if she'd
lowered the bow or if it was clear she
didn't have it in her to kill him that
would have taken some of the strength
back away from the character again but
they picked the perfect moment to have
that kid take her down and that was just
a great choice too i did feel a little
bit bad that jon snow might have to take
her out as much as i didn't like their
pairing i didn't feel like he deserved
to go through that either but for that
kid to get his little moment of getting
justice for what happened to his family
and taking it out on her i think that
was the perfect person to take it and it
happened at the exact right moment when
it should have number five catelyn stark
it's another red wedding death but it
does rain higher for me than rob i think
just because you know that the one who
they absolutely are after is rob and
rob's direct bloodline so you kind of
wonder if it's supposed to get is
catelyn gonna get killed because you
know she's never gonna raise an army on
her own she was only able to do so in
service of rob
making a go for the crown so there were
some points that even after you realize
rob's not gonna make it that maybe she's
not gonna die but as the the weight of
the whole offense sinks in you realize
no she's gonna die too but she does not
go down quietly takes out
walder frey's wife and then just
standing there and not even fighting it
when that guy comes up behind her and
does the exact same to her is probably
one of the darker deaths on this list
because a lot of the deaths on this list
i think are fun in some way or were
cathartic this one was just kind of
heavy but it was executed incredibly
well and in a way that really helped you
feel the impact because they sort of
slowed everything down for this moment
to happen number four
tywin lannister you know on paper
probably one of the most embarrassing
deaths to happen in this show or almost
any show that i can think of just to get
gunned down on the crapper i mean that's
a shameful way to go but you know what
for a guy who was as powerful as he was
and as high and mighty as he was and how
much
strength he had to go out like that at
somehow it just felt right and it was
cathart i've used that word a few times
here but cathartic for tyrion to be the
one to take him out because tyrion had
taken so much of his crap not only over
the course of this show but you really
got the impact of over the course of his
whole
life he'd been trying to please this man
and taking his crap
no more and he said no more with a
crossbow bolt number three
oberyn martell undoubtedly the most
painful death that is on this list and i
it's it's this high up for that reason
alone it's not one that i necessarily
enjoyed because some of these deaths i
enjoyed on some level either it was a
character i wanted to see die or
something was cool about the death
itself but this one i did not have fun
with but it impacted me so heavily i
can't not put it way up high on the list
you know i've said it before and i will
say it again i do honestly think this is
the most brutal death that i have ever
seen
anywhere in any movie in any tv show in
comic books whatever this is so
painful and not just the the instant of
death itself but as soon as you realize
that this guy is going to turn the
tables and take out this character who
you love
the instant you realize that happens
like oh no no no no no no and then the
beating and like the thumbs and the head
oh man it's it's
brutal it is so brutal it's brutal on
the character is brutal on the audience
and it is an unforgettable death i mean
this one still haunts me
i
i haven't watched it a second time since
this aired it i don't know how i'm gonna
manage to do it but
man
even if i never watch it again i will
never forget it number two joffrey
baratheon i suspect for most people this
is probably their number one death and
largely it's just because of how
lovely it was just to finally
see him
die
everybody wanted this guy dead every
character in the show everyone who
watched the show it was just such a oh
finally
thank you because i mean he was annoying
from the very first time you saw him and
he only got worse as he took so much
pleasure and just proved to be such a
sadistic bastard just tormenting and
torturing people not even just his
enemies just whoever happened to be in
the room it was just so
wonderful to watch him die and to sort
of see the panic in his eyes as he
realized what was happening to him
you deserve it buddy actually you
deserve worse than you got but i don't
know if there was a death that truly
would have been appropriately
vicious vile painful long enough for
this character but
even with all that
he doesn't take my number one my number
one goes to a death that i think a lot
of people actually don't remember
and it was the first death of a
character that i was happy to see die
and it was a death that sounded a
certain growth for another character and
it's a death that i think is just a
really cool death unto itself and that
is the death
of viserys targaryen that's right you
forgot about him didn't you you forgot
about daenerys brother from the first
season because he was not around that
long but very much like joffrey you kind
of hated him right off the bat so it was
just nice to see him die unto itself but
the way he was taken out i have a sick
sense of humor i love a clever ironic
death because he's in a situation where
he's caused a ton of problems but he's
done it in this temple where he knows
they are not allowed to spill blood and
the line that daenerys says to him you
will have a golden crown men shall
tremble to behold and him just be like
well that's all i wanted and he gets his
golden crown when drogo takes that
molten gold and pours it over his head
which is not only a
golden crown that he asked for it kills
him without spilling any blood and then
when he falls down and just the clang of
that cooled metal hitting the ground
oh
that's just an awesome death and a
character that deeply deserved it and it
just showed how fierce and vicious that
daenerys was willing to become
yeah
that is my favorite death in game of
thrones but there have been a lot many
many many deaths what is your personal
favorite death in game of thrones
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned